سأتحمل كل ما حدث لي، حيث
تقول الشرطة إن الأمر كله كان خطأ
[تصفيق]
في 23 يوليو من فريسكو، قامت ضابطة شرطة في تكساس
بوضع لوحات على سيارة دودج تشارجر سوداء
ولكن بدلاً من كتابة AR لأركانساس،
قالت إنها كتبت من الألف إلى الياء لأريزونا
عادت المعلومات باعتبارها
سيارة مسروقة محتملة تقول الشرطة إنها كانت نقطة
توقف مرورية شديدة الخطورة وأن ضابطًا واحدًا على الأقل
قام بسحب سلاحه لكل من في
السيارة ورؤوسهم خارج النافذة وأيديهم
بالخارج
احتفظوا بأيديكم بالخارج لمعرفة ما
إذا كان هناك أي أسلحة  السيارة
تخبر العائلة الشرطة أن لديهم مسدسًا في
السيارة في صندوق القفازات
إذا وصلت إلى تلك السيارة، فقد يتم إطلاق
النار عليك، لذا كن حذرًا ولا تصل إلى
السيارة
[موسيقى]
سمعت ديميتريا أنها كانت خلف عجلة القيادة
السيارة التي كان زوجها وابنها وابن
أخيهما
في طريقهم إلى بطولة كرة السلة،
وهي تشرح كيف كان الأمر عندما
ترى ابنها السادس الكبير متورطًا، لقد
أحضروه بالفعل مكبلين به
ووضعوه في السيارة وهم يمشون به
لوضعه في سيارة الشرطة وأنا بالفعل أبكي
ولم أقم بفرط
التنفس، تقول إنهم تلقوا
تعليمات بعدم التحرك،
وأوضح لي زوجي أن ابن أخي
هناك يصرخ حرفيًا لإنقاذ حياته
ويخبره  يا عم، نحن على وشك
الموت ولكن أخيرًا
أدرك الضابط أنه كان خطأً،
وتجري الآن مراجعة الحادث. أنا
لا أبرر أي شيء، أنا فقط أقول
أنه لم يكن جهاز كمبيوتر هو الذي قرأه،
لقد كان خطأنا البشري هو الذي فعل هذا
لذا يرجى أن تسامحونا، فالمراجعة المستمرة
ستحدد المزيد من التغييرات في
سياسات وإجراءات التدريب في القسم.
أشكر الله أننا لم نتعرض
لإصابات جسدية ولكننا عانينا
الكثير من الصدمات النفسية والعاطفية
من هذا.